all right so second example here and
then I'm going to set you loose on the
exercise this is a rational function
like the kind we look at yes they're
much simpler than the higher example we
did so can we work out what this thing
looks like now in this case again you've
got these options right you can have a
think about doing this by making the
right-hand side equal to zero
so the way I would do that is I would
say two over X minus three take away one
is greater than zero I look at that and
then I'd say hmm
this thing on the left hand side what
does it actually look like well I could
try and combine these two things into
one I could try and say it's gonna be a
two on X minus three take away X minus
three on X minus three it's greater than
equal to zero you could do some algebra
here and you could continue simplifying
okay however what I'm gonna try and do
is show you just like I did before you
can attack this either way I'm just
going to try and draw this guy over here
and then I'm gonna look for where it's
greater than one just to illustrate that
you need to have some flexibility in the
approaches that you use so let's think
about this for a second I'm just like
yesterday I'm gonna look for some
intercepts and then I'm gonna look for
some asymptotes so for starters if I've
got y equals two over X minus three
let's look for an x-intercept first so
what I do is I say y equals zero hmm two
over X minus three when is that equal to
zero
have a look at it closely is there a
value that makes that happen and it
looks to me like the answer is no
there's no value of X you could put in
there that would make this thing zero so
what that means is there's no
x-intercept that's what I was searching
for but I can't find one so I so I say
there's no x-intercept
but I look for a y-intercept and the way
I do that is by letting X equal zero and
this is much better I get y equals two
over negative three so negative 2/3
okay so I'll fire that that away in my
mind and then I think about asymptotes
as I mentioned
a vertical asymptote appears because I
look for when the denominator equals
zero it's not supposed to equal zero so
if I let it equal zero I'll get a
vertical asymptote X minus three is the
denominator equals zero so I get x
equals whoops that's a positive three
there so that's going to be my vertical
asymptote and I'll let you go ahead and
do your own working to show that the
horizontal asymptote will be y equals
zero as you put very large values of X
I'm you're going to approach the x axis
on both sides of the Cartesian plane
alright so now let's roughly graph this
thing let's go ahead and put on my
intercept I think I said it was minus
2/3 so I'm just gonna call that minus
2/3 that was my y-intercept there isn't
an x intercept and then I'm gonna do my
asymptotes I've got one at x equals 3
which shouldn't surprise us this is this
horizontal translation that we've seen
before so x equals 3 and then I've got a
horizontal asymptote of y equals 0 so
I'll go ahead and I'll label like so
okay what's it going to look like or you
can see over here on the on the left
hand side over here I've got to get
towards this asymptote I'm fenced in by
this other vertical asymptote and I've
got this intercept right there in the
middle so the only way that I can thread
all those needles together is to draw
this line like so and then you're going
to get a similar one on the right hand
side but opposite okay so this is
roughly what that hyperbola looks like
so now I want to say well when is this
thing going back to the original
question up here when is when is this
graph over here
when is it above or greater than 1 right
where is that where is y equals 1 I'm
gonna try and put a decent scale on here
so one would be around yeah here is y
equals one so which is the part of the
graph that's relevant to my solution
when is the hyperbola above this orange
line and you can see it right there on a
highlighter for you here it is this is
the section that I'm after so what I
need is the X values that's kind of
fence me in and give me the right domain
for that okay now you already have one
of the X values x equals 3
you can see I can't go anywhere past
that to the left as soon as you go past
that you get this part of the graph down
here which I don't want okay so that's
that's no good so I know that I'm going
to be to the right of three but then I
also need to be the left of this
particular value here where that those
two graphs intersect I need to find what
that x-value is so the way I'll do that
is I will solve for the equation right
I'll say when does two on X minus three
when does it actually collide and
intersect with that orange graph one now
please keep in mind this equation over
here is not the solution to my question
it's one piece of the solution it's the
intersection point so let's go ahead and
solve it I get two and on the left-hand
side when I multiply through by X minus
three and then all I need to do is add
three to both sides which gives me five
so you can see there I'm gonna fill that
in now get rid of that question mark
that's five there which arm makes sense
it's a little bit to the right of three
so now I'm ready to write my solution I
want to be between three and five
between three and five I look just
quickly back at my original question and
I noticed that the boundary is included
you see that it's greater than or equal
to one now what that would suggest is
that therefore my solution is between
three and five and what you would think
is that you would have the less than or
equal to signs between everything right
from three you start there and then you
go to five however you can see I'm sort
of hesitating I don't actually have the
equality here on the left-hand part of
it this is sneaky it's why I did this
worst example with you I wonder if
anyone can tell me why is it that I
don't actually include this boundary I
do include it here you can go up to five
and onto five and that's fine but you
can't do it over here on the left
there's a clue in the graph and I think
some of you are picking it up right the
graph is the key that's why we're trying
to show you that solving inequality the
graph is important the gap the graph is
the key instrument to know right I think
she's sort of snuck in and everyone's
kind of like yep what they said right
because there's an asymptote there
remember vertical asymptotes from
yesterday they come from discontinuities
in the domain yes so they come from
places where the domain sorry where the
function is not allowed to go you can't
go on to x equals three the function
just blows up right so as a consequence
you can't include the boundary in your
answer you can get as close as you like
to it but you can't actually get on to
three itself so therefore down here in
my solution instead of lesser than or
equal to I'm just gonna write lesser
than and I know that's a bit weird
that's a bit sneaky and unusual but
that's kind of why you can see the graph
tells you this it shows you there's an
asymptote there you're not allowed to go
there so don't include it in your
solution